one man's final journey home to la
cámara in the Canary Islands crossing
the sea from the neighboring island of
Tenerife his nearest and dearest want to
bury him on the island where he was born
and bred
oh I thought they'd be I make it it's
great that burials are free here there
are people here who can't afford to pay
for all of this para pagar el hierro de
hombre no I don't know where all the
money is coming from for all of that but
we're benefiting from it when if you see
on the on the island of La Gomera the
local government pays for funerals for
the burial the coffin a gravestone and
the funeral directors costs even for a
floral tribute the burial insurance
policy costs the authorities six hundred
thousand euros a year the head of the
Council believes that you shouldn't
scrimp and save in this respect this is
an essential service and we are proud of
it the citizens of La Gomera deserve it
this quick and humane service makes
things easier for the families II ill
man adanya the island with its twenty
two thousand inhabitants has become an
exception in Europe with its cradle to
grave welfare coverage but funeral
director toribio arteaga our ma isn't
happy he could earn more of burial was a
private affair some relatives would
decide for an upscale coffin the islands
council opts for a more modest model an
anachronistic state intervention in the
funeral directors opinion Bernadina
cynthia nadina cynthia looking for them
it doesn't make any sense being
europeans and taking this approach I
don't think this makes the island any
more prosperous on the contrary I think
it makes it por todo lo contrario cocina
pobres a llama
there are increasing calls for the local
government to invest in other areas for
example for the replanting of unique
woodlands raised in last year's forest
fires for environmentalist ruben
martinez Carmona that's just one of the
many problems that people on La Gomera
face our unemployment rate is the
highest in the Canary Islands and the
Canary Islands have the worst jobless
figures in Spain Spain has the highest
unemployment rate in Europe and we're
paying for people's funerals incredible
why aren't we investing in something
productive in the living rather than the
dead one problem of the free burial
policy is that it applies to all gum
aronson even those who are well off
nobody show not someone who earns 200
300 thousand euros a year doesn't need
this assistance but the islands council
doesn't see itself in a position to
means-test camerin families they say
that it would be too costly and
difficult many good Marin's live abroad
was every show near as hell just imagine
a grammarian dies in venezuela how can
we check their financial means that
would be impossible my opinion that mean
if someone has enough money to pay for
their own burial then they should
voluntarily forego the free service but
it's true no one does a verdad que nadie
lo hace
the island council has just renewed its
funeral insurance policy for another
three years yes they'll probably abolish
it one day if the crisis continues if
the islands Council runs out of money
then they'll no longer be able to pay
for our funerals but at the moment they
still can
300 people are buried on La Gomera each
year when patients die in hospitals on
the Big Island's it's costly to
repatriate the bodies and yet the
islands free burial service is a
blessing for many